so milk you goes off to meet the
coachman and the coachman has already
said he's collecting bad little boys and
he's got them on the coach they're all
delinquent types here and the ticket on
the coach was the ace of spades which is
what Pinocchio is holding and he's with
this character here called lamp-wick
that's an interesting name so he's the
he's the thing that burns in the middle
of a light lamp-wick and that's
interesting because it's a play on
Lucifer as Lucifer means bringer of
light and so lamp wicked the play on
that and lamp-wick is really a nasty
piece of work he's got this false
arrogance about him he's got this like
sinneth cynical voice really deeply
cynical voice and he's only I don't know
how old he's supposed to be in this
maybe twelve or something like that or
thirteen and so he's one of those kids
who has become prematurely cynical I'll
tell you a story about that so I used to
live in Montreal I lived in a poor
neighborhood and one day I was out in
the back alley building a fence because
I was putting a little fence around my
bat my little tiny backyard and there
was a house across the alley down the
street aways where there was a lot of
like not good partying a lot of bikers
were hanging around there and I knew
there was a little kid that lived there
as well anyways I was out there in the
back alley pounding away on my fence and
these little kids came up and they were
little they were like three and four
years old hey and they spoke as you all
right kind of really heavily accented
cable or French and so my French isn't
good so I could hardly understand them
but they were what they were watching me
hammer and they got a little closer and
they had one one kid who was clearly the
leader had a real scowl on his face hey
and so they were watching and I kind of
motion to one of them that they could
use the hammer and that kid said and I'm
going to mangle this but he said yeah of
olay or something like that and what it
meant is I'll steal that and so I
thought you know and then he came over
and he tugged on it and he wanted me to
take it and he was quite angry and while
I was and let him take it and then so so
I couldn't engage him I couldn't get him
to play you know when
his buddies were sort of hanging around
behind him and they wouldn't come and
play because he wouldn't and so he was
hostile right away to me and then so the
fence piece was laying out in the Le and
these little monsters started running
across it which I thought was really
remarkable you know but it was terrible
at the same time because they were
really little kids that shouldn't be
happening when you're like three or four
if that's happening at that age things
are not good and so that kid was already
like seriously not happy with the world
and you know I'd been studying
antisocial behavior for a long time by
that point and I knew that the kids who
are destined to jail later in their
lives are kids who are rough and tough
when they're 2 years old but then don't
get socialized or maybe worse they get
anti socialized which is exactly what
happened to this kid he'd obviously been
ignored and abused certainly no one had
ever played with him in any real way
because he wouldn't play and it's not
good if the kid is that little and you
can't get them to play something's gone
seriously wrong because they're so
playful at that age that like it's like
90% of them anyway so they were running
back and forth on this fence I thought
stomping on it you know and I was right
there I thought well I first of all I
thought that was remarkable but I also
thought it was absolutely horrifying
because you know in some sense I could
see where this kid was headed and why at
that early stage in his life it's really
it's not a pleasant thing to behold you
know but there was nothing that could be
done about it and that's kind of what
this lamp-wick is like he's prematurely
cynical this kid was already cynical and
he was like 4 years old you know most
kids don't get cynical till they're
teenagers you know and then often they
don't get completely cynical and usually
they more or less grow out of it but he
it had happened to him much earlier so
this lamp-wick character he'd or he's
already decided that he knows everything
that everyone else is his opinion is
worth nothing and that there's nothing
in culture or society that holds any use
utility whatsoever for someone like him
now you can imagine developing that way
if you were raised in a family where
people were generally lying to you and
that they randomly treat
you are neglected you and that you
couldn't discern anything about them
that was admirable or positive you know
of course you assume that the whole
structure is corrupt and that you had to
take care of yourself and no one else
well not of course not everyone assumes
that under those situations I shouldn't
say of course but it's a but it's a
logical set of conclusions so and of
course it's proportionate to some degree
to how much abuse you take although
there are lots of stories of people
who've been terribly abused as children
who grew up to be no kind remarkable
responsible thoughtful people who were
absolutely opposed to abuse instead of
propagating it
there's no direct causal pathway